- Do you guys want to hear
more about Toronto Dance Salsa?
So, I got a recent comment
from one of you guys
in Believe Nation from Alex, who said
Evan, would you make a video
talking about your experience
with Toronto Dance Salsa
or a regular series.
And, so I'm curious from
you guys, would you want
a regular series about
what I'm doing with TDS?
It'd be a little bit harder to
orchestrate and make happen,
but I'm curious to figure out,
is it something that you guy want to do>
Now, I try to bring up stories
that I think are relevant
when I'm doing an espresso,
or any of my opinion pieces,
I always bring in stories that I think
would be relevant to the topic,
and often that'll include
whatever I'm doing
at Toronto Dance Salsa or
something that's happened
in the past week or couple weeks
to try to inject a little bit more context
into how I'm thinking
and what I've learned,
and how I'm applying it to my businesses.
But it sounds like that's a
little different that this,
which is a series just focusing on TDS,
why we're here, what we're doing,
how we're growing it, what the vision is,
maybe involving some of my team at TDS,
so, I'm curious, is it
something you're interested in?
Pros and cons, let me know what you think,
and if there's specific requests
that you want to see, if
it's a yes, what's probably
going to happen is what we normally do,
we'll do one test video.
It'll be a test video, and
we'll see what you guys think,
and then we'll take action from there.
So, is it what you want to see?
And then, give me specific requests
for what you'd want to see
in that first test video.
If that works, we might continue,
if it doesn't work, then we're
probably going to cancel it.
We'll see.
So, let me know.
Make it great, what would a great
first video look like for you?
Leave it down in the comments below.
And, if you don't like the idea at all,
leave it in the comments below, too.
And we'll see what happens.
Thank you for the suggestion Alex.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, see ya soon.